hi I'm Lana Condor and I play Largey and
I'm Noah sentimental and I play Peter
Kavinsky and I'm his real Broussard and
I played Jos Anderson we're gonna find
out which characters we are from to all
the boys I've loved before only on
Netflix so choose a car to bring to the
bake sale we've got cookies which are
always a nice option cupcakes yeah
brownies yes Donuts muffins and last but
not least hi I'm gonna go with the
brownies because chocolate never fails
oh look a cupcakes because then you can
like cut them in half flip them and have
a cupcakes your own first and Lana I
mean oh you know I'm your friend cancels
plans last minute on a Friday night
what is your plan B stay home and watch
a movie texts your other friends to see
what they're up to go to a coffee shop
to quietly read a book head to your
favorite hangout spot text your crush
and see if they want to grab dinner or
go to the gym for a quick workout that's
not mine I'm gonna say hangout spot I'm
gonna go to a coffee shop and read a
book that's what I'm hopefully get
stirred up stay home and watch a movie
that's good probably a movie on Netflix
which accessory would you purchase for
your bedroom this fun quilt these bold
plant pots these statement wall
tapestries this beautiful candle this
cute planner or this pastel lamb same
pasta you same tie see resto because
pastels like you made that sound so
regal
I mean ha Stella and its own right is
very regal regal right uh I'm gonna go
with the fun quilt keep warm looks comfy
I love candles well what is it smell it
this candle it's like a light blue which
means it's probably sweet and I don't
like sweet candles will you I want like
a glad like a dark rum oh you know
woodsy right I'm gonna go with these
bold plant pots because even if there
wasn't a plant and then you could still
use it for life
keys change pasta soup okay pick an
emoji that speaks to your soul I can't
even do the flat face and then it's a
kissy face and it's the cry eyes
that's not crying that's laughing but
he's crying I use that one all the time
I understand where I messed up it's
crying eyes with the carrier's going
down like this with the stream it's the
steady like water waterfall you're right
all right I'm wrong that what you wanted
to hear
I want the glasses one it's so out of
these six that's just label all right
you're right I'm gonna go with the cry
face / laugh face eye bottom left bottom
with I'm gonna go with this one that's
just like the top one the first one is
the flat cuz I feel like that's like I
think I live my life like a little
scared and a little confused and I think
this one really speaks to me and a
little dead inside you look hopeless it
that is true which song are you going to
jam out to on your drive home from
school girls like you
by morning 5:00 attention by Charlie -
in my feelings by Drake which ones that
one kiss by duo lupa sit next to me by
Foster the People and solo by clean
bandit with us I want to [ __ ] but I'm
brokenhearted I've heard two of these
songs
I guess I'm musically illiterate but I'm
gonna go with attention but that's the
one I bounced in amongst a baseline I'm
going solo one kiss is the Wallach you
know that was yeah that's the one one
kiss see I'm getting busted songs I'm
riding solo
[Music]
just stay in the room oh yeah finally
she was a Korean dish to gobble down
kimchi okay bibimbap how to pronounce
the outside chip silk are you sweating a
little bit bulgogi bosun mm-hmm or chef
chai I only know what kimchi is I'm
gonna go with the big d man that's a
good one
I picked kimchi I got Peter I got Chris
yeah I got large gene and I actually
truly was I wasn't doing that on purpose
kind funny and a little shy you have a
big heart and a lot of feelings don't be
afraid to wear your heart on your sleeve
from time to time and trust her instinct
when it comes to love confident funny
and charming you put on a hard exterior
when you're really a softie on the
inside you care deeply about your
friends and family and would go above
and beyond to be there if they need to
do you feel like you're confident you
feel like you're funny
oh this is just a quiz if you like
you're charming I can be in the right
instances but most of the time I'm
charmingly like outgoing funny and
deeply loyal here's someone who isn't
afraid to stand up for your beliefs
while sometimes your mouth can get you
into trouble
yep true you wouldn't trade your
extroverted ways for anything do you
think you do you think you're an
extrovert I charged introverted ly and
then I like super outcome oh really it
has a great grasp on his personalities
we actually talked about this like on
set we were like you could have played
Peter like I can play Josh like it could
have gone either way we felt you are
Peter and I am honored can I be ready I
don't wish that I was job
[Music]